welcome everyone to the online
algorithms session
um our we're going to
stick with the format of most of the
conference which is to do
these five awesome talks in quick
succession
and save questions and discussion for
the end the talks are
on a pretty cohesive set of subjects so
i'm hoping that we can have some
some high level discussion at the end in
addition to
questions for particular authors please
feel free to record
questions in case you might forget them
either to yourself or in the chat and if
they're not answered by the authors
there we will get to them at the end of
the session
so without further ado let me introduce
christian from
cwi who will give the first talk on
metrical service systems with
transformations take it away christian
okay thanks a lot for the introduction
so this is going to work with sebastian
vubeck niv
bender and mark silke and we are
introducing here a new online problem
and before i introduce this new problem
i will give you the definition of an old
problem
which is called material service systems
so in this problem we have a metric
space
m and some initial point p 0 in the
metric space
and now at every discrete time step some
set is given to the algorithm some set
at which we call the feasible region
and then the algorithm has to go and
move this point to this region so if
this is the first set 80
and this is the initial point now the
algorithm has to go to this set
and then the next set is revealed and
again the algorithm has to move there
and the cost of the algorithm is just
the distance travelled by this point
and at this point we could also call it
the state of the algorithm
so this is a very general online problem
and loads of problems fall into this
class of metrical service systems so
some of them are listed here
but there are still limitations to this
class of problems
so um for instance it's not possible to
change the state of the algorithm
uh without incurring cost so
it could be that for maybe um resources
appear or disappear
let's change the state of the algorithm
but we don't want to charge cost to the
algorithm for this
so something like this could not be
captured by metrical service systems
and also a particular problem that
doesn't fall into this class of metrical
service systems
is the k taxi problem which is the
generalization of the k server problem
so this problem the the task basically
is to assign taxes to passengers
so as to minimize the distance of empty
rights of the taxis
so whenever we have a non-empty right of
a taxi
the state of the taxi configuration
changes
but we don't want to charge any costs so
this doesn't fall into this class
so to address these limitations we
introduced this new problem which we
call metrical server systems with
transformations
so definition is very similar again we
have a metric space
and some initial point in the metric
space
now at every time step well previously
we were just given a set at
now instead we received some function
that maps
a set 80 to some other set of bt
and that is the main difference so now
again the algorithm has to go to a point
in the set 80
and again the algorithm pays the
distance from the previous point
to 80 but now we apply this
transformation so now the new state of
the algorithm
is going to be the image of 80 under
this
transformation and
for this transformation we don't charge
any additional costs so now
the state changes without a charging
cost
and um yeah i'm going to come already to
the
main results of our paper so
we show that if the metric space
contains any points
and if every transformation is alpha
lipschitz
then the competitive ratio is roughly
alpha to the n
so at least when when alpha is large
enough then these
upper and lower bounds here are tied up
to this
two basically that's inside the um well
that's taking the to the power of n
um for the k taxi problem which is a
special case of this problem
we give a very simple proof to show that
the competitive ratio is
polynomial at most in n which is
the size of the taxi problem space
and in lock k and we also show a result
that we find
rather surprising which is that for
chasing comics buddies if you extend
this in this manner and you allow
contracting
transformations between two convex
bodies
then there exists no competitive
algorithm for this problem
so even though these contractions can
only bring the online and offline
algorithm closer together
the competitive ratio is no longer
finite even in two dimensions
and the main problems that we were not
able to answer is
well what are better bounds on finite
metrics
if we have contractions so in well
convex body chasing has an infinite
metric space
and contraction means it's a one
lipschitz function so we know from this
upper bound that there is
a competitive algorithm on finite metric
spaces but if alpha is one
then the lower bound we have here is
quite meaningless
it's just one um so it seems
possible that there should be a much
better um
competitive ratio for the case of
contractions also
for isometry transformations
and um i will not go in detail about the
proofs but i will um
state one idea that we use for some of
these results
which is if we look at the special case
symmetry transformations
which is in particular the case that we
have in
in the problem then one idea
is to say well
try to extend this isometry from a t to
b
to a global isometry of the entire space
so if we can do this then it means the
isometry is not really doing anything
it's just the renaming of the points of
the space so
if it's possible to extend such an
isometry in in this way
then to serve the request we really just
have to go to 80
which is the same we have to go in
metric with service systems
and then we just rename the points of
the space
so we could then just apply a metrical
server systems algorithm to this problem
but this is some well in some cases this
is possible to do but in general
you cannot uh expect to be able to do
this
one idea however is to first extend the
metric space m to some greater metric
space
so that we can then expand our
we'll extend our isometry to an isometry
of the global
of the greater metric space
so the question here is then
given some finite metric space n
is it always possible to find a
superspace m hat
such that every partial isometry on n
extends
to a global isometrial name ahead
and this is indeed possible so this was
shown
15 years ago well actually it's known
since 20 so since like 100 years that
this is possible
but 15 years ago it was also shown that
if m is finite then m hat is also finite
um so what this means is that the
problem uh
tmss with isometric transformation
reduces
to just sss on this extended space
and the competitive ratio because of
what
is known about metrical service systems
is therefore poly logarithmic
in the size of this extended space
the next question then of course is what
is the size of this extended space
so what is the size of m head
so it would be desirable if there is
some function
that bounce the size of m hat as a
function of
b so even though it is known that m hat
is always finite
we don't know whether such a function
exists
what we do give is well we do answer
this question for some special cases
like
for special classes or metrics of
isometries and also in there's a lower
bound
for some metrics showing that the
blow-up is at least exponential
we don't know if there's a better lower
bound so if this was tight
it would mean that there is a
polynomially competitive algorithm for
tmss with isometries so this is
one of the ideas that we use in this
paper in particular to obtain the
result for the k taxi problem and yeah
to get
um yeah more insight in into more of our
ideas
i refer to our longer talk or
of course the paper so that's it for now
thanks for your attention
thank you christian um you're the only
one i can hear applaud but i'm sure
everybody is actually applauding
um so if we could go ahead and change
over the screen share
to i think kevin
yes fantastic
yeah yeah we see them very good so we
have oh and i should um
mention i should remind everyone since
christian brought up that all i've
watched all the long
talks for uh this session they're all
awesome and
um all of you in the audience should
check them out so uh we have kevin i
think from cologne and maybe that's
correct i'm not sure
uh here to talk about unknown iid
profits better bound streaming
algorithms and a new impossibility
go ahead kevin thanks
okay so unknown iid profits that's short
for
profit inequalities for iad random
variables from
an unknown distribution uh so let's
first talk about id profit inequalities
um so what's the setting here um
yes so as input once given a
distribution on the positive real
numbers
and natural number n and then one gets
the sequence of independent draws
from that distribution namely an
independent draws
also shown up here um yeah
and the task is to select a single one
of these draws at the time when this
repeat
so let's walk through short example
maybe first uh this draw
so this draw is reviewed first let's say
it's eight
uh and now one has to decide whether to
select this
as a single one of these drawers or not
uh let's say
one doesn't and then this one's revealed
let's say
it's also not selected and this one's
revealed let's say that's
that is selected and since only a single
one of these drawers may be selected
all other drawers are rejected okay
we've referred to the the index of the
draw that's selected
also as the stopping time which
is also denoted by tau okay so that's a
very clean
setting what does the profit inequality
say about the setting
it says so it compares the expected
value that can be
selected in that setting with the
expected value of the profit
so the profit just sees all the values
in advance and just goes and
selects the largest one of these values
and then the profit inequality says how
these terms compare
so in particular in this setting
it says that the expected value that one
can get in that setting
is at least roughly 0.745
uh times the expected value of the
profit
and that is best possible
okay um just a short notice on
why that's interesting or why people
look at this other than that being a
clean mathematical model
um well it's um
yeah it's important in mechanism design
like pricing and
uh beyond the worst case analysis of
online algorithms
so that's actually a very simple online
problem of selecting the maximum value
right
all right um and now the next model that
we actually
look at um it
it changes this part of the model that
namely that the distribution is known
which is arguably somewhat unrealistic
maybe in practice one only knows sample
samples from that distribution
and that's yeah an assumption made by
azar kleinberg and weinberg
and more specifically in the id setting
and
a previous paper of hours or actually a
subset of the office
um yeah uh in ec19
and the goal is to essentially recover
such a result that i had on the previous
slide
um again comparing the the value of the
decision maker only knowing these
samples now instead instead of the
actual distribution
um with the value of the profit um
yeah we actually look at slightly at a
slightly simplified setting
where n is large so the number of
drawers is large
and uh also the number of samples is
linear
um in the number of uh of draws
and yeah one can argue which i won't do
here but during the long talk
uh that that's the most interesting
setting
all right um so
what what's known about this guarantee
as a function of the number of samples
so we have beta times n samples uh
and it's known that this the function
that's
um describes that guarantee from the
previous slide
uh is between is in this gap here
between these two functions
a particularly interesting case is b
takes one so you have as many uh
samples as you have actual draws in
which you can stop
um yeah so these are the ones from the
ec19 paper they've since been improved
um and that's what was known previous to
our work um so what do we do
well we extend the state of the art in
three directions one of them being
uh improvement of the state of our
guarantees from the last slide
so we'll show you in seconds how these
improvements look and how we achieve
them
[Music]
what we also do so we introduce
a streaming version of the model that
addresses another arguably an
unrealistic assumption namely that all
the data points can be stored
so maybe the number of
uh of samples that you have is actually
large and you cannot store them all
um yeah that's actually another
motivation of
for the class of algorithms we look uh
look at
for the first contribution um because we
can
implement these algorithms in that
streaming setting
uh the last contribution is that we
extend this
um impossibility so the very uh point on
the very left in that
diagram that i just just showed we
extend that to a more general
um but in the remaining few minutes i
will talk about
uh this first contribution and yeah
how we achieve that uh yes so the new um
the new bounds are shown in red so that
looks a little
incremental maybe but uh yeah let me
tell you why i think it's cool so
i think it's cool that um so we get
we get tight bounce for a whole range
range of beta
so that's actually yeah those are
except for the limit and this beta
equals zero case
those are the first tight bonds and also
some of our bounds are tied for the
natural class apartments
so what's that's the class of algorithms
well it extends the class or it
extends an algorithm from that c19 paper
um so that algorithm does uh
what that algorithm does is at each time
step it selects
a uniformly random subset of size n
minus 1 from all values it has
previously seen
and takes the maximum of the set and
sets this this as a threshold for
accepting next value
okay and we look at generalization where
we essentially
allow to select any uh a subset of piece
highs
at any point in time so we have a
function that maps time
to how large of a subset uh you're
allowed to um
select yeah that's dilemma we use
to analyze this class of algorithms so
let's look at these functions
yeah so yeah that's the number
the size of the subset as a function of
of time
what we in fact do is we look at the
continuous variance where time becomes
continuous
and then for some specific and what we
do is we
equidistantly sample that function and
from that we
uh we cover the the actual sizes that we
use by rounding
all right um so yeah this is less of an
intimidation slide than none talk but
here won't say much
what i want to show you is what the
optimal function in the end looks like
so that's in fact the optimal function
that we allow
that we compute from this problem using
a variation in calculus
yeah so this this function gives you the
the best sizes of
subsets um to select uniformly
advancement each
time step and um yeah when we add
bounds on the number of samples uh we
also get
at least conjecture test function but
that's a strong conjunction
okay and we we do so for for any upward
boundary number of examples
i will explain yeah these functions a
bit more in detail in long talk
um what i should mention is that from
some point onwards
so uh for 0.58 times n
samples and less uh we only get a line
for that function
and that's also the point in time uh
yeah a point where we um
get uh tight bonds so for every lower
uh number of of samples we also built a
timeout
all right um so that's all i want to say
thanks for listening thank you kevin
could we go ahead and switch the screen
over to spheros
[Music]
yes
okay spirit should be able to share
fantastic we have uh spiros with the
talk
uh online search with a hint go ahead
uh thank you very much so i will present
some results
on a new framework for online sets i
should say here that if you would like
to see some motivation that comes from
action movies you're invited to look at
the to
have a look at the long video but this
is a short talk
so for now i would like to say that what
we're trying to accomplish is this work
is we would like to be able to leverage
hints in a setting in which we have a
sensor
who wants to locate any mobile hider in
a given environment
uh right so i start with uh so we start
with
the simplest environment you could
probably imagine which consists
of uh the unbounded line with some
origin point
and there is a high there at some
unknown distances in
some unknown point essentially in on the
line it's either to the left or to the
right
and there is a sensor so the sensor
would like to look at the hider
it doesn't know exactly what it lies so
what it does is it follows the
strategy until it eventually hits the
target
and the strategy is completely defined
in this simple case
by the by the lengths of by the length
of these traversals back and forth
um this is a problem that of course is
known in operations research as a
as linear such problem in computer
science we know it's more informally as
a cow path problem
and the objective for the sensor is to
minimize the so-called competitive ratio
it is the worst case rise of the
distance that the sensor had to traverse
in order to locate
the target divided by the optimal
distance it would have to take
it would have to traverse if it knew
exactly where the hydra was hiding
so there's a there's a very well known
result that
using a double strategy we get an
optimal deterministic competitive ratio
equal to nine
and this is a problem that has been
discovered and rediscovered and
and extended many many times across many
disciplines
so in this work we're looking at we we
we're following the framework in which
there is some additional information
that is given to the sensor
and this information is given in in in
in the form of a hint and in fact we
consider two possibilities so one
possibility is that the heat caps from a
trusted source
which means that it's always guaranteed
to be correct or the hint
is uh comes from a malicious source from
an unstructured source and therefore
it can be generated adversarially
and now the competitiveness of the
search strategy
um is defined across two metrics the
first uh is uh what is called the
consistency because the competitive
ratio of the hit is correct
the other is the robustness the
competitiveness of the heat is
adversarial
so i should say here that uh what we're
really adopting
the untrusted advice framework that we
presented in the last
itcs but i should point out here that uh
now we are we're in a specific
application and as you'll see we have
very
specific hints with very specific
semantics
and also there's a there's a very active
field on online
computation about enhancing online
algorithms with uh untranslated
predictions so here is a simple example
if the hint is a direction of the search
so one possibility is for the sensor to
always trust the hint
but if the heat isn't correct it could
be walking towards one direction
uh infinitely two to them to the
infinity so it could be infinite
competitive
the other is to ignore the hit and you
would be uncommon and competitive
so the question is which one of these
two is best the answer is uh
they cannot be compared but we live in a
two-dimensional space so we can apply
the framework of pareto efficiency
in order to be able to to compare
strategies okay
so uh in this work we basically consider
three
types of heat so the first uh the first
type is the exact position of the target
so the heat tells you where precisely
the target lies on this infinite line
the second is the direction of the set
whether it is to the left or whether
it's
to the right of the of the origin and
the third the most general is that it
comes from a k bit string
um so so this is a more general
framework it's it is very much related
now to the advice complexity
in an untrusted uh setting and even with
one bit you could uh you could give
pretty much
a lot of information to the sensor so
one one bit
would induce a partition of the line
into two spaces into two subsets
and that would be useful for for the
sensor
uh i will very i will very briefly
discuss just the first one which is
perhaps the easier
um that highlights some of the
techniques here what happens if they hit
the exact position of the target
well what happens here is that we follow
geometric strategy
this is these are the classes of
strategies that work well in practice
um so the if in the ice iteration here
we'll locate let's suppose that in the
ice iteration we locate
uh the height there so we go beyond the
hydro so we find the height there
i'm using a length equal to br to the i
so what is br to the i
well br is defined here but there is a
there's a nicer way of thinking about
about it it is the largest uh base i
could use in a geometric strategy
and we always are robust in the worst
case
so i'm trying to work as far as i can in
each iteration without
without sacrificing robustness but also
this is a little bit wasteful towards
the end so what we do is really we
shrink it to make sure that we hit
the target precisely at the right moment
and once you have this idea the upper
body it's very easy to analyze the
strategy in this framework
it takes a little bit more more effort
to show the lower bound
if you uh and indeed we argue that this
is the best you can do you get pareto
optimality
uh and to show that this we need a
helpful lemma
we need to be able to say something
about the relation between
the lengths of these cells in any robust
strategy
in particular we need to say that the
eighth length
cannot be too big in comparison to the i
minus one and once you get this this
this follows um pretty easy
uh i will only give a summary of the
results we get for the other two
settings
so for the setting in which the hint is
in the direction uh we obtain again
pirate optimal strategies
uh and in terms of techniques we rely
some nice uh
results based on functionals by securing
and goal but we extend them in a
parameterized way
and this allows us to get pretty better
results uh in the following sense so
using these previous results by
themselves what we could so easily or
what
was already known was that uh the
average of
the of the robustness of the consistency
is nine
at least not okay but what we saw
is that if you want to approach to to to
make the consistency
much better in particular as you go
towards five
the robustness skyrockets it tends to
infinity
as as a consistency goes to five so we
get some better
uh lower bounds in the sense which are
optimal
and in terms of k-bit strings uh well
here we do not get tight results but we
get a collection of upper and lower
bounds
um i should say as we point out here
when i say up upper bound for general
are
the expression is a bit ugly so i did
not want to include uh
what is perhaps more interesting is is
the techniques we are using
so we rely on games between the
algorithm and the adversary
using some some information theoretic
arguments and uh
what i also think is interesting is that
that we try to relate the hint
to multi-cell strategy so we pretend
that there are a lot of searches who are
searching at the same time
all of them being robust they will let
the best one locate
target so i will conclude with
someone going in future work so it turns
out that this is a very simple setting
and and and and but the analysis is not
exactly trivial
uh there are still upper and lower
bounds we still have some gaps and we're
working towards
bridging these gaps and
another another interesting direction is
incorporating errors in these
predictions because in the real world
the predictions come up with some arrows
and towards this direction with uh with
science money we looked at an ai problem
uh so we looked at the problem of
contract scheduling with predictions
uh and this is work that will appear in
in
the next triple ai conference and uh
we're very confident
that we can incorporate these ideas to
these problems to this problem because
because they have conceptual
similarities uh we would like to
study of course radome strategies and
the fourth direction is i think what is
uh
what what is the most broad one uh one
could study
uh such problems beyond the competitive
ratio you don't need to confront
yourself to the competitive ratio for
the studies of these problems
uh in particular in in operations
research
people study sales problems either as a
sales game
between the hider and the sensor
or as an optimization problem
so you have some distribution concerning
the hider and you want to
minimize the average style and again the
same framework
could be applied to to this class of
problems so you don't
have to use you don't have to relate to
the competitive ratio so in this sense
i'm hopeful that this opens up a new way
of
looking into this class of problems
thank you very much
thanks very much uh could you go ahead
and deactivate your screen share so we
can just go over to
you sure
you should be able to share screen i
think
thank you thanks so much okay
uh we have yangon sheet on
uh online paging with vanishing regret
go ahead
okay thank you and hello everyone i am
yan ranchi from technion today i will
talk about online paging algorithms with
vanishing required
this is which john's research work with
professor ewa amek and professor sheikh
guten from tecnio
in the online pageant problem we are
given a main memory of sets an
under cache of zk the request sequence
over the pages in the middle memory
coming an online version in capital t
round in each warranty if the requested
page is not in the cash configuration
in such a case we see a cache mix
happens for example in this electrician
the cache mix doesn't have
any round one or run two but it does
happen here on three
because at round three the tiger page is
not in the cache configuration and when
the cache mesh happens we need to invite
an element in the cache configuration
to bring the requested page in for
example we can erase this rabbit page
to bring the tiger in like this and
for an arbitrary unknown page algorithm
its cost is defined to be the number of
the cache machines incurred by this
algorithm
and the objective is to minimize the
number of the cache misses
for arbitrary page i and around t we
define the next row time
not o i with respect to t to be the
first run
explicitly after t when the page i is
requested
in validated work in 1966 it is proved
that
the offline optimum can always be
achieved by algorithm which always
invites the page with the largest notch
when the catchment happens for example
in this electrician
when the cache mishappens at round one
the dark page it has the largest nut
over all the pages in the cache
translation
so the algorithm fit f the first is in
the future algorithm
it will inverse this stack page
and then for an arbitrary online page
algorithm arc
is required its defined to be the
difference between the cost of arc
and the offline optimum
our goal is to design online paging
algorithm with eventually required
which means that the ratio of the
required to the number of the round
capital t
tends to be zero when the capital g
tends to be infinity
however this is impossible under the
conventional setting
consider an invariant where n equal to k
plus one
and the required sequence is generated
at random
uniformly and independently it can be
proved that
in such a case the expectation of the
offline optimum
has an upper bound of big o t over k
low key meanwhile the expected cost of
any random algorithm arc
has a lower bound of omega t over k
so in our study we consider the setting
where the online region of realism is
given access to machine learning
predictions in particular for not
predictor
it will generate prediction sequence in
an online version for the net
of the requested pages for example in
this electrician
at round one the title page is requested
its real nut would be 3
which means that after round 1 the first
round when the title is requested
would be run 3 and meanwhile the
predictor will reveal
a prediction to the main algorithm is
and obviously it doesn't match the real
nuts
for prediction we define its cumulative
prediction error to be the number of
runs
when the prediction doesn't match the
real
uh your nuts like this run
and because the machine learning
predictors it can often be
has a high cumulative prediction error
which means that it
is not trusted and in that case in our
study we considered a setting where
the main algorithm is giving access
again to multiple predictors
and this it can be implemented by
machine learning algorithms
that are trained on different data sets
or using different machine learning
models for example in this electrician
we give another example of a different
predictor
which can generate different predictions
over the nuts
and how different cumulative prediction
errors
we make assumption that if we are given
multiple
excesses to multiple or predictors
then at least one of the predictors will
have a low
cumulative prediction error that is sub
linear in capital t
and we call this assumption as a good
predictor assumption
the question is if this assumption holds
then whether we can get a when she
rewrites before we describe our main
results for this question
i want to talk something about the
access model first
because the predictions are revealed in
an online version
there are two ways to defend access
model to the
predictions the first one is called the
full information access model
and the section model at every round the
prediction of all the predictors
are revealed to the main algorithm
by contrast in the second access model
in the bandit access model
in every round the main algorithm needs
to make
a choice over the predictions for
example in the first run it can choose
the predictor b and in the second round
it can choose predictor a
and only the chosen predictor can reveal
its prediction to the main algorithm
so obviously from a technical
perspective of you
this model will be more interesting but
more challenging
okay now i will talk about our main
results and we will start from
the settings with a single predictor and
we develop an algorithm theme
which try to simulate the algorithm fit
f but
replace the realness with the remedy
predictions that is
that are derived from the given
predictions
and it is defining history
and for example as in round one the
pre-tiger page is requested and the
predictor reveals a
prediction too and such a prediction can
be found to be wrong x
run 2 and in each other case we will
update this prediction
to be a large enough number z that is
larger than n
because without such an operation this
tiger page will almost always remain in
the cache configuration
and never gets invited and causes too
many prediction errors
too many uh costs and
if we such a technique we can get a
range required
that is bounded in this way for the
single predictor society
and now let's consider the multiple
predict setting and the full
information access model in such a
setting
we can simulate our theme algorithm
with respect to each predictor in
parallel and
for every such a theme algorithm we will
track its cache convolutions and costs
and mix all these algorithms with a
random
learning algorithm proposed by plum and
birch in 2000
and to generate a range regret bounded
by such a formula
and i would like to inforce that the
algorithm proposed by blam and birch in
2000 requires
us to track the states i mean the case
configurations and the cost
of our research algorithms which is
impossible under the bandit access model
so how could we deal with such obstacles
for the bandit access model
so we will probably develop a new online
learning algorithm
which doesn't require us to track the
states
i mean the cash configurations of these
algorithms
instead when the online learning
algorithm it chooses a new predictor
we do not switch our cash congregation
to the target algorithm instead we will
perform autism procedure
this teasing procedure it may not catch
up with the
state i mean the cash configuration or
the target algorithm
but we can ensure that the relatively
the relative loss would be bounded
just like the fact this electrician this
runner
will be our traditional algorithm
choosing procedure
and this swimmer or the cyclist it can
be the target algorithm
and we will always compete over
different states
but if we can try hard enough then we
wouldn't we wouldn't lose too much
and in this way we can get awareness
required funded by searches of linear
formula
yes that's all thank you
thanks uh we have one more talk so if we
could switch over to the last speaker
probably that's samson if you can go and
share your slides
okay and all the audience remember that
after this we will have
about maybe 15 minutes for some
questions and discussions so if you have
questions you can start thinking of them
you can start recording in the chat if
you like uh we have samson
from cmu to talk about sensitivity
analysis of the maximum matching problem
go ahead samson
all right uh thanks for the introduction
and this is joint work with fuji yoshida
um okay so sensitivity is a
quantity that measures how much a
discrete algorithm changes when the
input changes
so for this uh deterministic graph
algorithm a
on a graph g within vertices the average
sensitivity is defined as the
expectation
of the size of the symmetric difference
of
um the output of algorithm a on input g
versus the output of algorithm a on g
minus e
where e is taken from the edge set of g
for a randomized algorithm we consider
the expectation of the earth move
distance
between the distributions of a rather
than the
size of this metric difference and
i guess just to illustrate this
definition we'll give an example
in which we consider the greedy
algorithm for a maximal matching on a
graph with six nodes
so suppose we consider the graph in the
upper left corner
i claim that there exists an ordering of
the edges
for which the greedy algorithm gives the
matching
labeled in the two blue horizontal lines
in the upper right corner
on the other hand if we remove the
middle horizontal edges
and we preserve the ordering of the
remaining edges then the greedy
algorithm will output a maximal matching
indicated by the blue edges
in the bottom right corner
so the symmetric difference of these two
matchings
are the edges in red so the size of the
symmetric difference is three
so hopefully this gives some intuition
on the definition
so average sensitivity for graph
problems was introduced by marian
yoshida
and they considered a concept called
centrali which
quantifies how important a node is in a
underlying network
barman yoshida subsequently studied a
number of graph algorithms that output
edge and vertex sets
and pung and yoshida considered
advertising for spectral clustering
we introduced the definition of worst
case sensitivity and that's basically
just the average sensitivity but we
replace the expectation with a max
this definition is pretty well motivated
and it's related to other concepts that
are important for
studying online algorithms and dynamic
algorithms
for example consider a case where we
have a number of agencies that want to
provide as much service
to a number of clients as possible along
a number of predetermined routes so they
choose a matching
and then they they uh built some
infrastructure to support this matching
but now later down the road we have a
new uh
possible route up here and we still want
to
maximize matching but we don't want to
change as much uh infrastructure
so we want to minimize the sensitivity
of this graph
so the results i'll talk about today is
first a one plus epsilon approximation
to the maximum matching problem
with a constant worst case sensitivity
where we omit the dependencies on
epsilon and a deterministic algorithm
for maximal matching
with worst cases to be delta to the x
where delta
is the degree of the graph
so to give some context to our results
we
improve on a previous result by varma
and yoshida in two ways
the first way is that they analyze the
average sensitivity whereas we analyze
the worst case sensitivity
the second is that they get sensitivity
roughly you know n to the epsilon cubed
where n is the number of edges
sorry the number of vertices in the
graph whereas we get worst cases to be
uh of one
so how do we do this i mean the previous
example already shows that greedy
algorithm can have
worst case since v omega n
well the first idea is that we show that
randomized greedy for maximal matching
actually has sensitivity one so
randomized greedy is where we first
randomly choose a permutation of the
ordering of the edges and then we just
run the typical gradient algorithm
the idea is that the expected deleted
added edge appears halfway through the
ordering of the edges
so that seems bad at first because maybe
we'll still need a sensitivity omega n
but the intuition is that either most of
the edges in the matching
occur either early in the ordering if
the underlying graph is a dense graph
or the deleted and added edge does not
affect the edges in the matching very
much if it's a sparse graph
okay so now we have a randomized greedy
algorithm for maximum matching and we
want to go from maximum matching to one
plus epsilon approximation for maximum
matching
and we do this by modifying a layered
graph that mcgregor showed in a
multi-path streaming algorithm model
so the layer graph creates a graph with
l plus one layers
to simultaneously sample a large number
of augmenting paths of length
l so in this picture we have
um the underlying graph of
i guess five edges and the layered graph
that shows an augmenting path
in this um with respect to this mapping
the key concept is that if we terminate
this um
approach in roughly one over epsilon
iterations then we achieve a one plus
epsilon approximation because we've
sampled most of the augmenting paths of
length at least
one for epsilon so if we do this k
times where k is some constant that
depends only on epsilon but not
n then we get a worst case sensitivity
of 3 to the k
furthermore the runtime is polynomial n
m and k
so at a high level that's our
approximation algorithm to the maximum
matching problem
and now we'll talk about a deterministic
algorithm for maximal matching
our determinist algorithm has two
ingredients the first ingredient is a
deterministic
local computation algorithm by
conviction that produces a 6 to the
delta coloring of a graph of degree
delta
and the key part is that uses o to the
delta log star n queries
this algorithm works by partitioning the
graph into force assigning each node a
color
based on the least significant bit
differs between node id and the parent
id
and the key property that we use for
this ingredient is that the
deterministic lca
only queries vertices within distance
log star n
the second ingredient we'll use is a
framework by parnis and ron
that simulates local algorithms for
maximal matchings
using a deterministic lca for graph
coloring
with c colors and this framework uses
delta to the ofc
probes now this framework works by
iterating through colors and adding
edges to the maximum matching m
if no adjacent edge is already in m so
one can think of this as like a greedy
algorithm
by iterating over colors and the key
property that we use for this algorithm
is that the
framework only queries vertices that are
within within distance six to the delta
so combining these two properties we see
that at most
delta to the quantity six of the delta
n queries can be in the lca can be
affected by a single deletion or
addition
and that gives our sensitivity
so those are two algorithms at a high
level we also have a number of
algorithms
a number of results that include a lower
bound
for showing that um any deterministic
algorithm
has worst case edge sensitivity omega of
log star n
as well as an upper bound that considers
a notion of
weighted sense to be a normalized
weighted sensitivity for
maximum weighted matchings
since this is one of the first works
that looks at worst case sensitivity
there has been
you know already some subsequent work
but also we think there's a number of
interesting future directions to to look
at
um i'll refer this to uh the odd the the
long version of the talk
and thank you for listening i hope
you'll take a look at our paper
thanks samson um
at this point i'd like to ask everybody
who has permissions to
to unmute themselves so we can offer
some applause to all of the speakers for
about
15 seconds so if you could go ahead and
unmute
okay thank you all for your enthusiastic
participation
uh great so we have now
maybe 15 minutes um in which to have
some discussion both we can
have questions from the audience for
particular papers
um but we also i have a couple of um
panel discussion questions that i'd like
to kick things off with
so and uh the the panelists have not
been warned of any of these questions
so these are for the this is for the
authors of all the papers
um feel free you don't all have to
answer but
uh just a prompt discussion so a recent
theme
in online algorithms and we've seen it
in a couple of papers in this session
has been
um the use of
untrusted or somewhat trusted advice to
improve
um competitive ratios of online
algorithms
and uh i have two questions along those
lines
one is for each of the authors some of
you had papers specifically about this
but some of you had models discussed
discussed online algorithms which
suffer from certain lower bounds and i
wonder if you have thoughts on whether
having online advice in some of these
models could help
circumvent these lower bounds and the
second is
in this area lots of different models of
what online advice should look like are
floating around and i don't think
there's quite community consensus on
what it should be yet
so i wonder if you could offer any
thoughts on what makes a good model of
online advice
what what what conceptually should you
check for
when deciding if you've come up with a
good mathematical model this is open to
any author
i realize you might want to take a
moment to think
i i may uh can i take the first thought
please please um
so it is because i have thought about
these questions and you're right
um there is an advice in in our field in
theoretical computer science there is an
advice framework for online algorithms
but it has assumed that the advice
comes essentially from uh it's perfect
it gives you all the information you
want and sometimes it's very
unreasonable
so there are two i think there are two
directions one can place you you can
look at a really syntactic model of
advice
and not an information theoretic model
and this is difficult
i i don't know how this can be done but
it would be a good direction for
instance there are syntactic models
about classes of algorithms
models about greedy-like algorithms
there's a there's a there's an entire
framework that says what a greedy-like
algorithm is
called priority algorithms so there you
can actually saw lower bounds without
complexity considerations
and perhaps one could use a similar
similar model for uh for
for the advice framework but this looks
difficult so so to answer your question
more directly i would say
for upper bounds we look at what
algorithms we get
if we get reasonable advice for our
problem
and and and if it if it's if it is
robust
and for the lower bounds if the
information theoretic model works
great if it doesn't work so you have a
huge gap
then you need to get more creative right
that is what i would say
okay so information theoretic model here
means like
uh the advice is a bit string not like
the like one of the models that you
consider
yeah but also the the information
theoretic model
gets into two for instance you can get
algorithms that are non-uniform
uh for different sizes of the input good
different things
we don't have algorithms that work like
that so i don't want to have a framework
that gets me to do all the nasty work
information theoretically to filter out
these things i would like to have a
different model for them
but it's not obvious how to do it
yeah okay um
yeah so um yeah maybe i i mean i haven't
thought about that myself but um
yeah maybe i can at least mention a
paper in europe's this year that
looks at machine learning advice for the
secretary problem which is at least
closely related to what i talked about
um yeah so
um yeah and then
of course that's uh that's a way to
mitigate strong lower bounds on
on algorithms but i think a different
way is actually through
some profit inequality type of model
which has been looked at
so if if you assume that the uh the
requests don't
are not generated by an adversary but
the the adversary
rather generates uh the distribution
from which then uh
um the input straw so yeah
this had been looked at for i don't know
for all number type matching and so on
but
i think they are still yeah i think
there's still
a lot of room for uh for these types of
results
actually that that leads me to a
question specifically for you kevin
which is i
think i got from your talk that uh as
soon as you leave this iid setting all
just going to say exchangeable random
variables
already you encounter very strong
impossibility results
um we
i mean this is actually we only looked
at
exchangeable random variables for um
[Music]
yeah i mean this as an extension of the
setting without samples
because i think in okay we didn't really
come up with a
with a model that make sense to
then introduce the samples in the in the
general exchangeable setting
yeah okay okay that makes sense thanks
thanks for the question so um also the
first question
related to the metrical service systems
with transformations
so i can imagine that this can work here
because also well this year well last
year i guess
with a different set of co-authors i had
a paper at icml where we show four
metric
task systems uh we propose a prediction
framework and
show that you can do something for
arbitrary metrical task systems
which in particular means you can do
some
things for the service systems
um so it does seem plausible that
also if you add these transformations
you can probably still
make use of predictions but i yeah i
haven't thought about it in detail so
but it seems possible at least yeah
very cool
uh yeah go ahead
yes and so it seems that
the first question has been talked about
extensively talked
so i want to talk something about your
second question
i mean what would be a good model for
the advices
and yes in because in our people we
actually consider that
we have multiple sources of the advices
and
such such kind of setting i mean if if
we only consider a single source of the
devices then such a setting has already
been extensively
studied for the unknown pigeon problem
or the for the metrical stage
much metrical service problem or
metrical task system problems
yes and but the problem is that
on in these papers we can always find
different
definitions about how the addresses is
different
defined for example we can define the
advice to be the notch
or we or something like the state of the
optimal algorithm
and yes but i think that we need a more
generous
definition about the advices i mean a
definition of the advices that can hold
your generally that for the knowledge
application dependence
on problems for example in our study we
consider a setting where we are given
the pre-stage
advices which means that we are just
given the predictions
of the whole uh required sequence
and such a setting of course it doesn't
depend on the
real problem and it doesn't depend on
paging problem
it doesn't depend on whether we are
having mts problem
and so on and we call it the explicit
explicit predictor setting and such a
setting it is general and we hope that
such a setting can be also studied and
the uh and other problems and we
actually get some good results for such
a problem but the problem
for this setting but the problem is that
for such a setting
we cannot expect that the predictions
are given in an
online fashion because suppose that for
the unemployment problem
if we at run one we are given we are
just given the prediction
for the page that is requested round one
such a prediction makes no sense because
we are we are just getting the
request as such as the current run so we
need to
assume that we can get the predictions
in our offline cycle
in an offline manner all the predictions
uh other
advices are given at the beginning so
this would
be some this one advantage of such a
general model
and yes and i think that we will we
would continue to study
this um this idea yes
thank you so before the session
officially ends at 12 30 i want to make
sure we have at least a moment for some
questions for the from the
uh from the audience so i already i saw
a hand from
uh mayank bhaskar mike do you want to
ask the question
yeah hi i had a uh on
general query uh with respect to the uh
this
online class of problems for the
optimization perspective so i was just
thinking what uh uh strategies do the
panelists thinks
uh uh think are the most uh
impactful in terms of uh
taking the priors out of the offline
uh algorithms and tuning it with respect
to those
online uh on
[Music]
data flows that come along
and maybe uh also try some
sort of a distribution shift with
respect to the uh
data uh in the case of suppose
if i take uh
federated and learning for example
so i was thinking more in terms of
optimizing these sort of
approaches and what do the panelists
think
so i i think the question has to do with
uh bringing online optimization
strategies into
the uh offline optimization strategies
into the online
um setting and how to deal with maybe
distribution shift over
time there uh yes yes in short yeah
it's a big it's a big uh big question
yeah it's a general query so i was
thinking if
unless half time
well let's let's also remember that
they're uh
for for queries that maybe require some
offline thinking there
are slack channels for all of these
papers um
for for discussion but we'll
um okay i everyone is welcome to hang
around but i should tell you now that
it's 12 30 so
um officially the coffee break is
starting in gather town
um i am happy to hang out here for
another five minutes or so if anyone
would like to ask
more questions of the panelists i have
more questions for a few of you if you
want to hang out but i can also write
you on slack
christian can i ask you so i don't know
anything about this
uh k taxi problem but just intuitively
why is why is poly n a reasonable kind
of guarantee here like
if i really think of it in terms of how
it's
named somehow i think of the metric
space as having many
that a taxi lives on is having many more
points than the number of taxis so
poly n and log k seems like a
weird combination yeah right i see
because you because in general n is
going to be much bigger than yeah i
think of the metric space as being
bigger so can you
can you hope to improve this poly n or
can you maybe have a more structured
metric space and then
get a get the poly n down to poly log n
or something
yeah so i don't think that this upper
bound that we have is tight
so that there was a previous part on
this k taxi problem where we showed them
like in a different paper due to the k
log n
which is more in line with what one
would expect so compared to that we
have a double exponential improvement on
the k dependence but we're exponentially
worse in terms of the n
dependence and the reason we get this is
because we take this approach
that we model the k taxi problem as like
we we view it as a metrical service
system with transformations
and then we get a metric space that has
k to the n uh many points basically
because we have to look at the
configuration space rather than the
so so there is a endpoint metric space
for the taxi problem
but if we model it as a metrical service
system with transformations
then for this problem it's a metric
space with k to the n
many configurations
and then we extend the space so that we
can extend these isometries to global
isometries and this makes it a 2k
to the end size space roughly and
yeah then the polylog of that is is
giving the
the log of um of n and k uh well
the polynomial and n and k yeah yeah
thanks uh i also have a question that's
for both young wong and
spiros and then maybe we'll let
everybody go because we're running over
time
um which is in both of your papers you
have
this advice notion and in both cases
i think there's some sense in which if
the advice is not exactly right
the the algorithm reverts to
some worst case kind of behavior so and
yangon's paper i think one
one thing i mean by this is that um if
the next arrival time
is not exactly right for a page um
that's the algorithm basically gives up
uh on using that
that advice that's my impression
understanding anyway but it intuitively
seems like you know suppose i
get the next arrival time almost right
like i'm off by one or something like
somehow that seems like it should still
be
useful information and i'm wondering if
and spirits you sort of brought this up
at the end of your talk in terms of
having approximately correct
hints i wonder either both of you could
comment on whether that's conceivable to
use
sort of information which is almost
right but not quite
uh well in fact in our in my study we
consider lights
we are giving a sufficiently many
predictors
and so maybe some of them
will have a high prediction error it is
not very accurate and
has many many errors and we cannot
sufficiently utilize its information yes
but we should assume that at least one
of them has a very low
cumulative prediction errors which means
that we can always ultimate because
the optimal the optimal ism can always
optimize the information from this
predictor
and not optimal but our benchmark the
benchmark can
utilize the information from this
predictor
and also i want to say that even if we
are given a wrong
not even if it is very wrong we will
still perform
some operations based on this knot of
this page
but we will correct our mistake
for in the future for example at some
run t we make a long operation
for self by electing some good pages and
then after 10
rounds or after 20 rounds we find we
find that oh
the that run prediction about the nut is
wrong
and i need to correct my mistake so
i will try to update the prediction
to be a large enough number which
doesn't make much sense
so that the page with a wrong prediction
can be evicted as soon as possible so
that's what we can do
and we find that it can work if they
predict it can you help us to ensure
that
the period at the cost our the loss of
our
algorithm or the regret of our algorithm
can be bounded
with the prediction errors and this is
for the single predictor setting
and so if we are given multiple
predictors and
in such a case we our algorithm will mix
which is
between the predictors i mean we suppose
that we have all the information
in for the predictors then we will track
the status the stage states of this of
all these predictors and jump over these
predictions
to to catch a low cost
and yes that's what we do so we will try
to find which one would have uh
will can give us the best advices
which predators can give us the best we
are trying to explore this
so
should i say something on this sure if
you feel like it no obligation
uh if you want i can answer i can try to
answer your question
so if i just start correctly you're
saying okay so what happens if you
incorporate
errors really and what changes yeah you
know suppose i i give you a hint but i
you know in your in your simple example
where the hint is of location on the
line you know i'm off by epsilon
you're right so so there are some cases
where you're going to be off
by a lot so this doesn't help in fact
this is addressed in the other paper
that we had a little bit subsequently to
atcs
uh and and there we did look at we did
exactly that so
so we said there are situations where
you if you are off by a little then
these these pareto
uh relations break down but you have
also to consider
what you do in this case so if you don't
you have now three parameters to jungle
if you
the the two extreme the consistency and
the robustness and you have also what
happens with uh
in the between what when you have some
sort of partially correct hint
so judging all three is by itself
difficult
and it's even more difficult i explained
to you why because
the problems at least i consider here
are non-monotone with error
so so let me give you an example so you
could have a horrible strategy in which
you walk too much towards in one
direction
and you and you come back okay you can
have you know a a a prediction that is
awful so it points you to completely
wrong
spots and you have huge noise and you
get
you get the the the what you get as
prediction is right at the point you
were turning
in this awful strategy so your often
strategy
with horrible error is perfect
so if you want to if you want to filter
out these things
you sort of can and we do this in the
paper and i actually
would i would be happy to explain you
where we do the statements of the
results are
more tricky than the results themselves
because you have to think about how to
what you can say in this context and
what kind of relations you can do so
it's uh
at least for this kind of problems that
they consider is a little bit is tricky
more in terms of modeling than in terms
of uh
for the for the query model it is a very
interesting open problem that i don't
know
yet how to solve all these things uh
there it becomes even more uh then it
becomes a real
problem it's it is the relationship
between
if you don't want to rely on buying on
noisy binary sets you have to do
something else
that's on the very high level um yeah
i'll be happy to point out exactly
um i think for for the time being we
should probably adjourn and
let people go to the coffee break uh
thank you again to all the speakers
you're all awesome
and i will see you around